[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview
a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive it's time to see
what's making the headlines with the
editor of the sheffield star nancy
fielder and the former government
special advisor
mo hussein they'll be with us right
through until
midnight let's see what's on some of
those front pages
now a pandemic chaos is set to continue
for weeks the guardian warns following
new advice which could allow
some to avoid self-isolation
the sun leads with court proceedings
against the manager of the welsh
national football team ryan giggs who's
been charged with assault and
controlling behavior towards his
ex-girlfriend
the accusations which mr giggs denies
are also on the front of the mirror the
telegraph
the telegraph meanwhile reports on a new
anti-obesity scheme which will
incentivize people to buy more
fruit and vegetable
the number of migrants who've crossed
the channel in boats
has now reached 22 000 that's according
to the times
the daily mail says prince harry will
release four books
as part of a deal but the second will
only be released after the death of her
majesty the queen
and where off is the headline in the
express as hundreds of thousands prepare
to go away
for the summer holidays
the financial times says law firms have
recorded huge profits thanks to soaring
demand for their services over the
course of the pandemic
coffee shrinks your brain proclaims the
star as scientists
say too much can cause dementia
and we're joined tonight by nancy
fielder and mo hussein there you are
good evening to you both thank you so
much for joining us
um let's kick off shall we with
the olympics and one would have thought
that it would be
all over the front pages but that isn't
really the case today
um mo start us off with page four and
five of
the mirror yes well
as we've seen even with the football and
the euro sports
is a really progressive force and a
really big unifier but clearly the
context
this time around for the olympics one
time seen as a bigger show on earth
is very different we saw a very poignant
strip back and somber affair today
uh for the opening ceremony in japan a
real tribute paid to the millions of
people who've lost their lives
due to covid and a really empty stadium
you know the stadium can hold about 68
000 people and yet there are only 950
vips
so i think it has set the tone for
excitement people are excited for their
national teams the athletes are
certainly very very happy to be there
but the olympics have caused a bit of a
stir locally as well with the kobe
rates rising again in japan i think a
lot of local a lot of local residents
uh questioning whether it's the right
thing to do and protest happening as
well
so probably a bit of a mixed bag this
time around
nancy um what did you make of the
opening serum you know a lot of people
online saying oh it was fantastic but
quite a few others saying
it actually was a bit sad in that empty
stadium
it was very mixed wasn't it i mean it
was spectacular the fireworks
were incredible and there were moments
that really lifted your spirits
but then it was against this backdrop of
an empty stadium there were messages
about the pandemic and about lockdown
and about the terrible losses woven
through so it really was quite unique
and very representative of where we are
um and as has already been said lots of
people are against this and they're
protesting outside
saying that lives should be more
important than the olympics and
lots of other people are really keen to
get going
and so i i think enthusiasm for it
certainly when we're watching from the
safety of our own homes on tv
we'll rise and we'll and we'll be
grabbed by the excitement it is a
fantastic event and it's been really
difficult two years for all these
athletes
but yes mixed messages right from start
to finish as we've had for the last
year and a half it has been a very
difficult year hasn't it and
you said that about the athletes it it
it does come obviously
in this um this pandemic year so for the
organizers it was very difficult but if
you look at the um the actual athletes
they they go in cycles don't they have
four years
but then if you add a fifth year to that
i mean
some of them won't even make it mo do
you think
that we're gonna come home with lots of
medals this time
i hope so fingers crossed i think we
need to wait and see i think the heat
is proving quite tricky for uh a lot of
people
um but we can be we can be hopeful i
think we have a good team
um i think it can be done but we need to
wait and see
yeah um nancy what do you make of our
team let's just have a look at the times
and the back page there
and obviously dina asha smith um her
comments today
saying that you should be able to
protest it's a basic fundamental human
right
absolutely and it does seem that the
olympics committee
is agreeing with that i know people have
spoken out against her but then people
have spoken out about anti-racism
gestures right the way through
this isn't about politics and it's not
about bringing politics into sport
it's about fighting racism and she's
absolutely right
if somebody wants to be able to make a
small
very small rather quick protest while on
a massive
international stage who who should stand
in their way
and perhaps when these type of protests
were taken in the 1960s
if more people had supported them then
we wouldn't have been having to do it
now in 2021.
um dinosaurs had said it is a basic
fundamental human right but the ioc
disagree don't they they say it's in
their charter
you mustn't protest um during the medal
ceremony mo what do you think
yeah i think the irc should look again
at their charter because
saying racism is wrong is not making a
little political point and it's not
protesting
it's something that most people should
find actually quite
easy to agree on and an event like the
olympics
is a brilliant platform to get that
message out there to
campaign for racial equality so uh
protests is one thing but i think by
lumping anti-racism
into a protest movement or a political
movement
i do think the ifc have got that bomb
nancy you mentioned
um what happened in the 60s we spoke to
john carlos a little earlier
he and tommy smith were expelled after
that protest
do you think that the world has changed
since then or we saw with the euro 22
final perhaps it hasn't
well i think the world has changed but
racism has most certainly not gone away
and we can all see this this
is an international gathering isn't it
look at the people that are representing
our own country and how actually they
represent our country
in terms of their color in terms of
their gender much better than most
organizations and companies in this
country sadly
much better than the public sector it
looks they look like england looks
and if you look at you've got all the
countries coming together people of all
colours why would this not be a good
place
to say that we believe in equality and
we don't believe that racism should
exist any longer
mo how do you think they're going to
deal with this if they do have
athlete after athlete on the podium
taking a knee
and in their charter and before the game
they've said you can't do that
you can protest before but don't drink
during the medal ceremony
i mean what are they going to do do you
think
i'm not sure they can do very much to be
honest these athletes will have
huge followings huge popularity across
the world
from the countries that they originate
from and if they choose
to do that during a medal ceremony um
the
committee the organized committee will i
think look very much on the wrong side
of the argument if they try to intervene
or if they penalize people
for uh saying that racism is wrong so i
think
uh it may be uh the carpet may be swept
underneath their feet on this
and they may just have to evolve and
rethink their
own rules and their own strategy because
um
doing anything else i think would make
them look pretty out of touch
nancy do you think that they'll go as
far as um expelling athletes as they did
in 68
no i think they'd look up to ridiculous
and what message would that send to the
world
but they are saying that sort of during
they're not it's not they're not banning
it completely or that it's the medal
ceremony that they're saying people
shouldn't be taking then they are making
what they're calling protest but
actually that's the key moment is it and
that's where we see the photos
that last four generations so what are
they going to do to stop them they can't
they can't physically stop them so why
would you not just support what is a
very powerful message
and join the anti-racism campaign let's
talk about their performance um mo what
is this
page eight of the times they have to
have special pills because it's
so humid yeah it's because it's so hot
there that they have to take these
pills that can transmit their
temperature
via bluetooth which sounds
slightly scary but actually i think
temperatures are going to be up to 35
degrees
and they've already been doing things to
get ready for the heat
like training and heat tents taking lots
of hot baths and saunas
so this is all a part of their
preparation and i think it's probably
needed i think
there was an athlete from russia that
fainted who fainted
a few days ago because of the heat uh
people who live in tokyo have been told
not to exercise outside or spend too
much time outside because the heat
so it's it's a real concern and it will
be a real concern
for for uh the uk team and others so
seeing this kind of
innovation and uh science help them
i think is probably a good thing they
should have just been training here the
last week it would have been fine they'd
be all set for tokyo
it's been quite awful okay let's go from
the olympics to the pandemic or the ping
mageddon
as i heard um this week
self-isolation crisis threatens a summer
of chaos
on the railways um that's on the daily
telegraph nancy just talk us through
that one
yes so this is trains and actually it
reaches all sorts of public transport
all forms of public transport
that can't operate because there are
just too many members of stuff from the
conductors
to the train drivers to the people who
serve the drinks who are having to
self-isolate and actually we've seen
quite a few examples of this already
train services being cancelled and all
kinds of things buses impacted
because people are staying at home and
obviously
schools have broken up now and it's
going to get worse people want to travel
more
and there are so many people
self-isolating
because of the pandemic it's just
impossible to get places
and just think about how many people are
having staycations and all wanting to
travel around the country because they
can't go anywhere else so it does sound
like it's going to be a recipe for
disaster and the government is going to
have to do something fairly quickly
on all sorts of self-isolation levels
but actually travel
is a key one what do you mean they're
gonna have to do something quite quickly
well are we gonna have no trains no
buses no food on the shelves i mean
they're gonna have to come out and do
something aren't they they're already
making these concessions so that we can
get
food moving and we can give special
special
no need to isolate um lists go ahead
some to some areas but actually
transport is very very fundamental
and it's not just about holidays is it's
about people getting to work
emergency services people getting to
work perhaps so something is going to
have to give here otherwise we're all
going to be back home because we can't
get anywhere anyway
i'm looking at the government guidelines
now it says the test to see if you can
be exempt
is um applied when identifying if an
individual could attend work is whether
they work in critical
elements of national infrastructure and
whether their absence would be likely to
lead to the loss or compromise of this
infrastructure
resulting in and then enlist some stuff
we don't have time mo what do you think
of um this list of exemptions
i think it's quite narrow and it seems
quite bureaucratic
and i think it's designed that way
because the government doesn't really
want that many people to be
captured by it and to be exempt because
self-isolation is now one of the only
things
the government has left to fight
the pandemic having lifted all these
restrictions that we were all living
under this is the one tool it has in
reserve and i think you will need to use
it
uh quite carefully so there clearly are
pressure points uh there are certain
jobs
uh where people haven't been able to
turn up which is which is having an
impact on
everyone's day-to-day life and that is a
challenge for the government but i don't
think it wants
this list to be too broad or too wide
because it defeats
the point uh and it needs to have
something
it can say that it's still doing to try
and control the pandemic
having lifted pretty much every other
regulation we were living under
we have a ping dermit because we have a
pandemic as uh jay harris
told us today hello again you're
watching the press
preview with me now the editor of the
sheffield star nancy fielder
and the former government special
advisor mo hussein hello again thanks
for hanging around
um let's start with the times um and the
latest wave of channel migrants to hit
22 000 nancy just talk us through this
this is their front page
yes so what this story is about is the
number of migrants risking their lives
because they are so desperate to find a
safe country
to come to and actually is going to be
more than ever
this year is what the story is saying um
tell as we can all imagine pulling a
hair out and
getting very annoyed that these numbers
are going up
but there are suggestions that the
changes that are coming to make it
harder
to settle here if you entering the
country illegally is creating a big rush
and good weather is adding to that and
actually people are pouring in
um looking to this country to help them
and it's incredibly controversial it's
doing exactly what the government said
they
it's doing the opposite of what the
government were hoping for they wanted
to stamp this out and it's actually
getting far worse
it was interesting this week wasn't it
we had on the same day images of
migrants as you say risking their lives
to come here
and jeff bezos building a spaceship to
take him to
you know to outer space all the limits
there of mo what do you make of this
front of the times
yeah i think it's a real a real big
problem for the home secretary and
uh we are real concerning downing street
because the numbers are so high and
getting higher particularly after
the government has announced new
immigration bill and uh
tougher measures to try and combat this
i think the really serious point though
is
that something does need to be done
about these criminal gangs who are
benefiting
from this misery and making money out of
people
uh people's journeys and the thing the
government should be looking at
is having these savings directly from
the most uh
conflict areas of the world where the
most vulnerable people you can't afford
to pay
smugglers and who are maybe physically
unable to make these journeys the ones
who really need our help
help them directly from the region so
they don't have to make
these kinds of journeys and the
smugglers don't benefit from them
um nancy let's have a look at the front
of your page the sheffield star
um just talk us through that one so
tram lines festival a massive festival
in sheffield every year
obviously except last year when it
didn't happen is finally up and running
this year there are people
packed in hillsborough park no mass no
social distancing it's a trial event
they've done the test before they've
gone in
and they are having an incredible time
it's very hot and sweaty in sheffield
perhaps not as hot and sweaty as at the
olympics
and but the irony is this festival is
called tram lines and actually
a lot of trams in sheffield have had to
stop i've got reduced services because
most of the staff at home
self-isolating so you open up some
events
and other key services fail some people
are really keen for
trauma has been waiting forever and
others think it's
it's a disaster and it should never be
able to go ahead it's very interesting
how everything is dividing opinion this
year
it was very interesting emo what do you
think about this because when they did
those
events in liverpool and they tested and
traced everyone they didn't have a huge
outbreak of covid
what do you make of festivals now
restarting while everything restarting
but in particular festivals
yeah i was pleasantly surprised at the
events program in that lots of different
things were tested
uh and tried and actually there weren't
that many big outbreaks at all
i think festivals um have suffered long
enough a lot of
people including myself enjoy going to
them and i think as long as
you have the reassurance that everybody
else who is there
uh is uh safe and protected has either
been vaccinated or shown a negative test
then i think they can and that they
should go ahead it's the kind of thing
that we
as a society have really really missed
and it's a part of getting back to
normal but in a safe way that gives
people
confidence to actually go to these
things and enjoy themselves